Nuestras mejores supercomputadoras clásicas son cada vez más potentes,
y cada vez somos mejores en computación, incluyendo la simulación de sistemas.
Pero simular la naturaleza es un problema muy difícil en general.
Me llamo Victoria Lipinska y hoy vamos a explorar uno de los algoritmos
que podría hacer posible simular la naturaleza en una computadora cuántica.
Empecemos con un ejemplo y pensemos en la cafeína.
Es una molécula sencilla.
Para representar la configuración energética de una sola molécula de cafeína,
necesitaríamos aproximadamente diez elevado a la 48 bits.
Eso es un diez con 48 ceros
y equivale a aproximadamente el 10% del número de átomos en la Tierra.
Y en realidad, la cosa empeora.
Si tienes 125 orbitales y quieres almacenar todas las configuraciones posibles,
necesitas más memoria
en tu computadora clásica que átomos hay en el universo.
Eso es imposible de representar con supercomputadoras.
Sin embargo, hay esperanza para las computadoras cuánticas,
porque son intrínsecamente buenas simulando la naturaleza.
Para una molécula de cafeína, eso significaría representar
el sistema usando 160 qubits.
Eso suena mucho más manejable.
Se han propuesto varios algoritmos cuánticos que permiten
a computadoras cuánticas más pequeñas simular la naturaleza de forma heurística.
Aquí entra en juego el variational quantum eigensolver o VQE.
VQE es un algoritmo que se ejecuta en parte en una computadora cuántica
y en parte en una computadora clásica.
Nos permite encontrar valores que resuelven un problema de optimización dado.
VQE está muy relacionado con otros métodos que involucran
variación de parámetros, como el quantum approximate optimization algorithm.
Identificar aplicaciones de VQE en tu industria o investigación
es todo un arte, aunque hay pautas generales.
En general, VQE es aplicable a problemas que pueden formularse
como un problema de optimización con variables continuas.
Este es el caso, por ejemplo, en gran parte de la química cuántica.
Muy a menudo, en química nos interesa el estado fundamental.
El estado fundamental es el estado de menor energía del sistema.
Para encontrar la energía del estado fundamental, VQE explora
la energía para diferentes configuraciones del sistema
y busca la configuración de menor energía.
A grandes rasgos, VQE recibe una descripción del sistema cuántico
y busca la energía mínima.
Lo hace variando la configuración del sistema.
Para empezar, tenemos que proporcionar una descripción adecuada del sistema
que la computadora cuántica pueda entender, y un conjunto de parámetros que lo describan
y que serán optimizados.
La parte cuántica del
algoritmo prepara el sistema en un estado
descrito por un conjunto dado de parámetros y calcula la energía.
Mientras que la parte clásica es responsable
de optimizar esos parámetros en cada paso.
Este proceso cuántico-clásico se repite
hasta que alcanzamos la energía mínima.
Ahora ampliemos el zoom en lo que ocurre bajo el capó.
La configuración energética se describe típicamente en el Hamiltoniano,
que generalmente es una matriz muy grande.
En álgebra, para encontrar el menor autovalor de la matriz
correspondiente a la menor energía del sistema,
simplemente haríamos una descomposición en valores singulares.
Sin embargo, las matrices que analizaremos son de tamaño exponencial
y hacerlo algebraicamente es un problema exponencialmente difícil.
Este Hamiltoniano tiene que representarse en una forma
que la computadora cuántica pueda entender.
Es decir, traducido del lenguaje de la química al lenguaje de la computación cuántica.
Pero no te preocupes por los detalles.
En definitiva, existen formas programables de traducir el Hamiltoniano habitual
en química a un Hamiltoniano comprensible para una computadora cuántica.
Luego introducimos este
Hamiltoniano junto con el circuit, que llamamos forma variacional.
Elegir una forma variacional es todo un arte.
De nuevo,
representa nuestra mejor estimación sobre cuál podría ser el estado cuántico del sistema.
Este circuit variacional está parametrizado con un conjunto de parámetros theta,
y también introducimos una elección inicial de dichos parámetros.
Con esto, la parte cuántica del VQE:
prepara el estado de referencia, por ejemplo, el estado cero;
usa un circuit cuántico parametrizado, la forma variacional, para preparar un estado cuántico
con una estimación inicial de parámetros en la computadora cuántica; y estima
la energía correspondiente al estado evaluado mediante el Hamiltoniano.
Esta estimación de energía se envía entonces
al optimizador clásico, que encuentra un nuevo conjunto de parámetros.
Los parámetros regresan de nuevo al solver cuántico,
y todo el proceso se repite.
La computadora cuántica encuentra una nueva estimación de energía,
el optimizador clásico encuentra un nuevo conjunto de parámetros, y así sucesivamente.
Repetimos este proceso hasta que la solución converge.
Es decir, hasta que la diferencia en los resultados entre pasos es suficientemente pequeña
para nuestros propósitos.
Al final, el algoritmo devuelve esa energía minimizada.
Bien, esto está muy bien.
Pero quizás te preguntes cómo sabemos que esto realmente funciona
y que no encontraremos accidentalmente una energía más baja de la que buscamos.
Esa es una muy buena pregunta.
Resulta que nunca podemos estimar una energía más baja.
Esto se debe a algo que llamamos principio variacional.
El principio variacional establece que el mayor límite inferior
de la energía del sistema es siempre su
energía mínima, correspondiente al estado fundamental.
Esto significa que la energía evaluada en cualquier otro estado del sistema
siempre será mayor que la energía mínima.
Por lo tanto, con VQE nunca podemos obtener algo
inferior a la energía del estado fundamental.
Sin embargo, sí podemos converger a algo
mayor que el mínimo que buscamos.
Esto se denomina a menudo una solución metaestable
y es un desafío que los investigadores intentan resolver a diario.
VQE es útil porque usa circuits más superficiales
en comparación con otros protocolos que nos permiten estimar la energía del estado fundamental.
Esto lo hace adecuado para hardware cuántico a corto plazo.
En este video, tuvimos una visión general de lo que puede hacer VQE y cómo está construido.
Pero te animo a explorar Qiskit en este contexto.
Aunque todavía estamos al comienzo de nuestro viaje cuántico,
es posible que ya lo encuentres útil para los problemas que estás intentando resolver.
Me llamo Victoria Lipinska y esto fue una visión general
del algoritmo variational quantum eigensolver.